lui aussi avait des groupies trente ans
après la disparition de claude françois
le souvenir du chanteur reste vif à la
fois sur les ondes et physiquement avec
les performances de ses sosies pardon
ils assurent le spectacle c'est presque
du cloud cloud comme nous le montre à
stiring wendel en moselle ce reportage
de rené le km et frédéric mendy elle
m'appelle michael silver j'ai 47 ans sur
une aire de metz est ma seule passion
c'est ça
cette 1re édition
à
cependant très peu élevé
julie sauvé lundi
tu me chercher
s'il écrit camaro bon mais aucune autre
n'est donnée remontée mallet
j'ai bien ensemble et que j'ai chanté
depuis le petit âge sur les chansons de
claude françois lavoie est venu donc au
fil des années naturellement giret et
avoir envie par la suite donc de faire
du spectacle et me produire sur scène
avec des clodettes avec les costumes et
me produire donc devant une banque
publique que je dis rien
quand je chante que de françois c'est
vrai que j'ai la pression parfois être
je me mets un petit peu dans la dans la
peau du chanteur et puis je ressens
quelque chose de grandiose de magique et
je pense que c'est là où je me sens le
mieux
une étoile filante qui maquille nommé
c'était un artiste mon copain niveau
donc celles beaucoup de jeu scénique les
paillettes les strass les couleurs les
ses concerts terminés avec des ballons
la musique en chantier en chantier le
public
lefrançois les clodettes sur scène
il restera il remplace